in this video we will compare all of
godzilla's faces from the first movie of
1954
all the way to the 2021 singular point
movie which is yet to be released
this year and we will also include
godzilla jr
space godzilla and all of shin
godzilla's form seen in the movie of
2016
so tell us which one you like the most
godzilla 1954
when godzilla first appeared in the 1954
film he has a bulbous snout
sharp teeth small pointy ears on the
back of his face
and also angry eyebrows but with small
pupils in his eyes
and small nostrils like a double barrel
shotgun in godzilla raids again of 1955
his second appearance he has few changes
from the original
his eyes seem to be less angry but with
pupils that are bigger in size
his head is smaller in comparison and
his teeth seem to jut
down and are jagged in appearance in
king kong vs godzilla in 1962
in his fights with king kong godzilla
has a more lizard-like head and his ears
have disappeared his fangs have also
gone and his eyes seem to be yellow in
color unlike the first two
in mothra vs godzilla of 1964 and in
ghidorah the three-headed monster of the
same year
when he resurfaces his head looks to be
bigger and wider
his eyes are white again and he has two
smooth eyebrows
his mouth also appears to be bigger in
size
in invasion of astral monster of 1965
godzilla has a more goofy appearance
with bigger eyes and a less rougher
texture
and also his head is rounder but with
sharper teeth it is here that he dances
for the first time
in emperor horror of the deep of 1966
the angry eyebrows that godzilla usually
has is less definitive
giving him an even more friendlier look
his head is slightly larger
than the previous one in son of godzilla
in 1967 the head was horrible
with stubby nose and face oversized
mouth with a
with crude teeth and large glassy eyes
placed high on the head at right angles
he also has a very ugly sun which we
will never include in this video
and destroy all monsters 1968 he is seen
with
more defined eyebrows and a fairly
menacing eyes the eyes never move though
though the eyelids flutter a bit briefly
in the scene when ghidorah
flies overhead at mount fuji in almost
this attack of 1969
godzilla vs hidora in 1971 and godzilla
vs gigan of 1972
godzilla in these three movies appeared
to look the same with round eyes
while the mouth had a frowning
expression and in the one versus gigan
godzilla actually had the ability to
speak
in godzilla versus megalo in 1973 he had
a
short stubby neck with round the face
and a stubby nose
the face was ghastly it had oversized
brows
and huge eyes that made the king of the
monsters resemble a puppy
in godzilla versus mechagodzilla in 1974
and the terror of mecca godzilla 1975
the muzzle was reduced and given more
detail which means the nose
the height of the brows was lowered and
the eyes reduced to
an acceptable size the new face just had
a semi-goofy semi-mean look
in the return of godzilla in 1984 for
the rebirth of the godzilla legend
touhou decided to once again portray the
king of the monsters
as an evil creature so his fangs and
ears makes a comeback
in godzilla vs biollante of 1989 biogoji
makes his first appearance with a more
predator feline look
and a second row of shark-like teeth
that makes him even more
menacing and his eyes have large brown
irises
and very little white showing in
godzilla vs king ghidorah 1991
his looks is the same but we see the
proto-evolve
form the godzillasaurus that has a head
similar to a t-rex but also looking like
a crocodilian
with large canine teeth in godzilla vs
martha in 1992 and godzilla vs maker
godzilla 2 of 1993
and 1994 versus space godzilla his head
is flatter
he has golden eyes and thick neck with
pronounced ribbing
the golden eyes made the face look more
expressive
space godzilla as seen in the 1994 film
looks evil with a more reptilian than
the g-man himself
his mouth looks similar to biollante
with sharp teeth jutting out with a pair
of dust on each side
has angry brows golden eyes and the
iconic orange yellow crest on his
forehead
in godzilla vs destroyer of 1995 junior
godzilla
has grown up from his cute puppy-like
face and seems to resemble an adult
godzilla but with a green texture and
golden eyes
the tristar zilla from 1998 has the most
deviated look of a godzilla if compared
with the rest
with its iguana face mutated to look
more dinosaurian
with a hammer-like chin and i would
personally say
it looks like the arnold schwarzenegger
of godzilla's
in godzilla millennium 2000 and godzilla
vs mega gears of 2000
he appears to be greenish in color and
with a very reptilian face that looks
angry
as hell along with very sharp teeth that
juts out from his mouth
in giant monster's all-out attack of
2001 godzilla is formed from the ghost
of world war ii victims
and therefore he has a ghastly look with
white eyes and a less reptilian face
with no ears and charcoal black in color
in godzilla against mechagodzilla of
2002 and tokyo sos of 2003
the head was completely changed and made
smaller to sort of represent the head of
the heisei series godzilla
but it looks more canine or wolf-like
with smaller eyes
and two large upper k9 teeth in godzilla
final wars 2004
godzilla retains the similar look as to
previous two films but seems to be
slimmer
with sharp ears and red eyes this
version of godzilla is the last of the
millennium series of films
in shin godzilla of 2016 he is seen in
the beginning as a tale which is the
first form
so the second form is actually the first
phase of shin that is seen
and it has large wobbly eyes and a mouth
that seems to have just recently formed
with teeth that are sharp and the skin
is sickly yellowish in color
in shin's third form he still retains
those wobbly eyes
but he is now reddish in coloration now
and the skin
seems to look like molten and scarred
flesh with rows of teeth that are dagger
like an appearance
in shin's fourth form shin godzilla has
now further evolved to possess small
whitish eyes that can be covered
in a dictating membrane that is black
silver in color
shiny the skin is reddish black and he
has the most demonic look of all the
godzillas
with the jagged teeth set in narrow
multiple rows
in its last and final form seen in the
movie shin godzilla
it seems to have evolved to look more
humanoid in appearance
with a round head that is cracked in
between this form has reptilian teeth in
a primate kind of a skull
in short it is a nightmarish creature to
look at
in the anime films as godzilla earth the
head features a more natural
and a normal shape almost akin to that
of a sea turtle slash crocodile
hybrid when looked at from the side its
eyes are now blue in coloration
and lacks natural teeth having instead
two's like appendages forming from its
skin
in godzilla 2014 and 2019 the design's
face is blocky
its head is broad and has shocked like
gills making this the first godzilla
design to feature gills
his eyes are small with a golden yellow
coloration and
his teeth are small and the nostrils are
more separate
on opposite sides of the snout and
making him more reptile in appearance
in shinkansen henke robo shin galean the
movie
snow godzilla features a mostly heisei
inspired design
that appears to have both the original
godzilla 1954
and shin godzilla's design merged
together he looks feline with puffy
cheeks and straightly lined sharp teeth
in the upcoming godzilla singular point
movie as seen from the trailer and the
official art
godzilla seems to be more crocodilian in
appearance
with saber teeth that jot down from the
upper jaw large
saber teeth canines we are just waiting
to see this next look
and now we come to the end of this video
so like subscribe and smash that
notification bell for regular updates
till the next one take care fam